that was
the
hardest chess game i have ever played in
my life
[Music]
here is the thread
ladies and gentlemen i dm'd him good
luck today uh tweeted at him all right
he replied you're done for i said loser
has to post a picture on their instagram
and a cat made outfit he said unlike you
i don't own a cat made outfit to which i
replied oh ho i'm mr beast i can't
afford a cabinet it's a cat made outfit
bro you literally walk around going and
i quote this is a lamborghini
okay so he's got a lambo but he can't
afford a cat made outfit
and then he said if he can go white
pieces first then it's a deal so
chess.com make sure he gets white pieces
first if it's black pieces first i abort
we talk for a bit and i say all right
well if this chess match goes awry for
you unless you head to poker
you know what his next message was deal
100k
does he think the subathon is still
happening does he think i'm sleeping on
stream a hundred [__] racks no shot
no shot
stop calling me poor stop calling me
poor because i can't do a 100 000 heads
up match
that is actually bullying it's poor
shaming
okay sorry i'm gonna try it and then
one more time i think
we've got ludwig's perspective of his
playing the scandinavian defense as he
did in their game at pogchamps 3. i
think he was supposed to go
something else
all right we're just gonna do a regular
scandy
maybe it's with the white pieces
i'm forgetting after ludwig developed
the bishop to f5 the pawn on b7 was
hanging and it's not only about the pawn
but the rook that was stranded in the
corner mr beast would have been up a lot
of material nothing was looking at that
part of the board but was too focused on
his own development getting the knight
out pushing the pawn castle and it was
missed by both players that bishop's b7
would have been an extremely strong move
for white yeah both opponents are tunnel
visioning but i must say compared to mr
b's last performance i think that ludwig
is underestimating how much preparation
he did like he actually has a very
comfortable position i like this he's
gaining the space kicking out this
bishop beautiful development with the
bishops i think uh ludwig was
underestimating him a bit
all right sticking with the plan
sticking with the plan so he wanted to
go inside
it looks like a very close matchup and i
love his pawn blunder i think he's doing
it on purpose because if the queen takes
the pawn then you have rook b1 and the
b7 pawn is in trouble as well as the
king he's happy about it
yeah
it's happening rugby one now with
whichever rook and then the queen has to
go rook takes b7 it's almost a checkmate
attack then the king will be in trouble
oh my god
it's happening he sees it did he
calculate this all we got was those
little happy groans but i think that
means yes i see the mates
before things are going good
so everybody thinks that you're being
[__] good for me indeed let's listen
to
i just gotta i just gotta keep firing
things at them keep firing things is he
gonna no he didn't see it
he's still attacking but now ludwig will
have a chance to defend
good decision dude he's crushing it
still it is so difficult to defend if
the rook comes to b1 then b7 eventually
will have to fall if mr beast pushes a4
that will help the attack of white by
trading the a pawn on b5 and then a
potential sacrifice perhaps with knight
takes b5 and then the rooks will be
attacking with full force that's the
full force mystery is talking about he
just shouldn't have
gone dude full force
mr beast okay i was told that this man
did like one joke
don't stop
attacking me
he has been grinding
if you're not on the left side of the
board hitting his king i don't want he
can have my king
he's killing it oh my goodness
oh wow
i'm feeling better
oops
okay what is this gonna see now what mr
beast was up to he was already
calculating it earlier i showed it
earlier because mr beast was ready to
sacrifice his rook
[__] it
he's looking very pleased
wait this isn't supposed to happen i
didn't actually think i had a chance yo
you got to be kidding me
he's cutting the king he took the pawn i
believe not just for the pawn but to cut
the king on the e5 not let it flee
yo is anyone else watching this what
am i doing nobody's watching
we have a whole produced show
he's like sitting not streaming like
in his house in his room
they're just a chill chess game nobody's
watching i think you still can't believe
that it's actually happening that he's a
few moves away from checkmating one of
the favorites
gonna happen
all right now my new plan is to uh draw
doing it oh my goodness
wow he's doing it king e7 and the poem
promotes next move text i'm so happy
i really thought i jinxed him i really
thought i did i'm
i guess you can stop the game if it's
gonna be still made but mr beast is back
on his a-game he did miss
a winning opportunity a couple of times
earlier but now let's see that technique
and if he can checkmate and not still
meet
got plenty of time
the king coming closer and he knows it
oh he knows he's happy
[Laughter]
i can't believe i just beat him oh my
gosh
yes oh my gosh none of you none of you
thought i was gonna beat this man none
of you look at that that is right oh my
gosh
oh my god did anyone just see what i
just did holy crap
oh my gosh dude he was
cracked
i told you guys mr you guys had 90 10
odds i was like no shot it's 90 10. mr
beast is good he made me sweat last time
he's making me sweat this time too
he's
goaded dude and now with the black
pieces can he hold it he just needs a
draw
it's a very different mr beast in
comparison to the one that played the
first game with the all-in attack he did
so well in that game and and maybe some
of his his energy
is being drained by that first game it
was a long game in the end it was a
minor piece and game that he had to win
but what a game it was for mr beast and
i i believe that even though lavig
obviously is upper piece he's the higher
rated player but everyone makes mistakes
and nothing can still go wrong too so
i'm expecting that the evaluation bar
will still have a few swings here and
there
i can't believe that from a piece of it
ended up being equal material equal
number of pawns uh no i'm very bad at
counting it's not equal
he didn't see it last time my never mind
never mind my prediction is wrong
all right and start seeing it and
capturing it let's listen in with ludwig
now what a relief for him
that we're 1200 rated at best
all right get the knight out of there
first and foremost
the night out of there
he to win it as a king and one second
let's block him from going to the right
the only way we can confirm if there was
something
under the table bribing is if we get a
stalemate
i think it will be very unlikely
scenario that ludwig doesn't win this
end game he seems to know and be very
sure of what he's doing in the singing
opponent game he didn't even want the
knight to be part of it
he's got the whole back row
always looking for squares he's very
overwhelming i go here still this is the
whole back row
he's the whole background no stalemate
i was joking about the bribing
um but maybe maybe i was right
mr b speeded himself up wait right now
why are we definitely just doing it for
content there's no way if i play g7
then i'm attacking this and now he's
switching this guy's protecting
the king blocks this square
and it's attacking this square there's
no way he doesn't know how to win this
in fact it'll be he's super cautious
about not stalemating now he realized
that that king went over the next one is
not the best
imagining the king is here
my pawn is here
okay i think he got it he can take me
here but it doesn't matter i'll get a
queen now he has to be careful though
because if the king comes closer that is
a stalemate
i mean
i've only heard of a few people who
didn't answer mr b's phone call it did
not end well for them you always pick up
the phone when mr beast calls
very true
what are you doing
the money you could get is much higher
than this prize fund
there we go
checkmate on the board what a comeback
by ludwig mr beast applauding
performance in the second game as you
said andra this means that we're gonna
have our first ever tiebreaker in
pogchamps four so we're gonna give the
players a few minutes to get ready for a
sudden death blitz game it's going to be
three minutes with two second increment
and the first player to win a game will
win the match hello
hey i was gonna say hurry up and end me
jesus it took you like 45 minutes to
kill my last little piece there at the
end dude i was
i was nervous all right well i'm winning
this next game sorry for beating you
why does he have to be better
than me at chess he has the white piece
as a reminder this is the tiebreaker the
rapid match it was 1-1 both have won one
game each and now whoever wins this game
or the next game whoever wins the first
game was winning the match
overall three minutes with a two second
increment it's a lot shorter time
control let's see who's gonna be the
speedier and more accurate player
oh my god there's only three minutes ah
oh my god oh what i was wondering why
nothing is taking it's so chill he now
has realized that it's a blitz tie
breaker indeed it's no longer 10 minutes
and then go here
he doesn't have time to think indeed
he has to move the bishop there's only
one squad he's giving up the bishop too
now he's gonna be two pieces down i
think ludwig will not let this chance
slip fit two pieces up now there's no
past pawn it's not that scary for white
anymore except for the time
the time and the two extra nights this
is now also the rook with the night
fight lovely is taking every single
piece one by one ludwig is cleaning it
up
he
i mean i know that mr beast played some
bullet but i think ludwig had a huge uh
upper hand here it it could only be this
miraculous past pawn that somehow if it
gets through the seventh rank will it
make it yeah
but now b8 is a threat that b682 is a
threat
wait a second oh my god
two squares to promote two squares to
promote so he can't stop both oh he's
going to the wrong square with the king
now the knight can move away with a chat
check oh god oh no that was so that was
he had to go elsewhere he had to go
elsewhere
now the rocks that was the pawn that was
oh that was so amazing
absolute miraculous comeback it could
have been
yep
well i don't think he's gonna you know
last time ludwig was baiting the
stalemates
but he knows exactly what he's doing
he's bringing out the king
could
still potentially be stalemate but no
ludwig has no mercy literally 50 wait oh
there was increment i didn't realize
there was increment yes there's a two
second increment so three minutes plus
two seconds increment he has now
collected a lot of time went all the way
up
[Music]
yes yes
i love mr b's reaction oh my god dude
oh actually oh my god they're not
waiting game on game one they are not
waiting this is now the second blitz
tiebreaker well
yeah he really does that's true
okay nice defense i would love to see
some sneak attack over here on g2 with
the bishop buying and potentially the
rook g4 jimmy going for the attack even
in an end game will he play g3 jeez
we're trying to undermine
bishop's protection dude this plan i
don't know if that was his plan from the
beginning but this is genius the thing
the pawn is directly [__]
indeed
so whether pawn takes or palm push the
bishop drops like should not touch that
f phone should play something else leave
it there
i think now
oh
okay it looks like the line is trading
the rooks and then once you trade
everything white can win the pawn on g2
i mean sorry could it be the case the
mover there will matter though he takes
on f2 first and that allows the bishop
to guard e12 so now the gt pawn will no
longer be left alone so i'm assuming
black all they have to do is just keep
this pawn defended
yeah so you gotta keep that pawn
defended and going back to b6 wasn't
really needed that allows white to get a
bit more space maybe push b4 in the
right moment still should be very
difficult being extremely careful
defending the pawn and then he will push
the c pawn
good technique here by ludwig who put a
lot of pressure on mr beast in
a drone end game but even jordan games
on the time pressure you can make a
mistake and that pump push off mr beast
the c pawn push was the big mistake he
knows it he knows that he might not get
another chance to steal me with the
queen down i mean with ludwig's
performance today if i was mr b sides
him 50 50.
then hopeful but no i think ludwig has
learned his lesson too many times today
i think he learned that i think this
will lead to a checkmate he's taking the
last pawn of mr beast making sure that
he cannot lose on time
or even if he loses on time he wouldn't
lose the full point
yep i had a feeling you know he wants to
feel confident he knows how to check me
with two queens there we go nice
that was such an impressive match
do wrong what a relief for ludwig
but it looks so relieved that was
the
hardest chess game i have ever played in
my life
mr beast it felt like you surprised your
own expectations what a match it has
been
yeah it was funny because uh before the
match you guys said like what was it
they bet three million points on blood
100 000 on me i was like oh no no i now
i gotta win yeah i mean it's the same as
last year like you're you literally do
the same thing every single day i know
your first 25 moves like the back of my
head i know the first 25 moves i
honestly could have pre-moved them all
but i was worried you would notice and
then so i had to like literally sit here
and count to ten and then move and then
count to ten and there's like a part
where there was a free pawn and i didn't
take it because i still had ten more
moves to make and i was just like we're
doing these uh and like i just had
someone literally study your last like
200 games and like you do the same thing
every time it's hilarious so like we
were at the exact spot 20 moves in that
i knew we were going to be in i'm not
gonna stand for this defamation yes it
is true that i do the same moves but
last year i thought you were like into
chess because queen's camp it just came
out i thought you were like i'll hype on
it this year all right i've been seeing
you been into a lot of poker and you
texted me i have no idea what i am doing
you're deaf going to win ha ha so i was
like oh this jabroni is going to be
you dude you could have literally moved
like any other pawn in the game and i
was screwing i'd be like trying to take
a pawn that's not there and be like oh
what do i do my plans
[Music]
you